[Musik]
Australien das Outback es ist halt
dieses Spiel so am Limit man muss an die
Grenze gehen immer immer mehr Leistung
und darum geht es in diesem Rennen das
härteste solarrennen der Welt wir fahren
gerade im Schnitt so knapp 100 nur mit
Sonnenenergie die S auf jeden Fall gut
schnell unterwegs bei der World Solar
Challenge
2023 ein vne steht hätte ich jetzt nicht
gedacht doch längst nicht alles läuft
nach Plan das will man nicht wahr haben
dass es passiert ist das Team
Sonnenwagen aus Aachen will es dennoch
schaffen 3000 km bis ins Ziel nach
Edy der Hidden Valley racetrack in
Darwin die erste Bewährungsprobe für die
Rennteams von Universitäten aus aller
Welt morgen wird die World Solar
challengeer durch Australien gestartet
und heute findet das Qualifying statt
also das Rennen auf einer Rennstrecke
und dem entschieden wird welches Team
als erstes starten darf nach jahrelangen
Vorbereitungen spüren die Studierenden
den Druck der Konkurrenz mit dabei aus
Deutschland das Team Sonnenwagen aus aen
Z Jahre lang so hart zu arbeiten und
heute hier zu stehen fühlt sich absolut
sural an und ja ich hoffe ihr genießt
den Tag ich hoffe ihr genießt die
folgenden Tage es wird mega anstrengend
aber es wird auch mega mega
geil einfach jetzt das ist genau der
Moment worauf wir hingearbeitet haben
und es fühlt sich ein bisschen unecht an
weil wir so viel darüber geredet haben
wie es denn sein würde und jetzt wir
wird die Realität und wir haben un so
gut vorbereitet hoffe ich und ja jetzt
schauen wir mal was
kommt das Qualifying beginnt erst ist
die Konkurrenz
dran die Z Minuten Marke für eine
fliegende Runde wurde bereits geknackt
als der adelie Getaufte sonnen Wagen aus
aen an den Start
geht und adelie ist schnell fährt die
bis dato schnellste Runde im
qualify während der solarenwagen im
Anschluss den Slalom und Bremstest
besteht drehen jedoch noch die Favoriten
aus Belgien ihre Runde auch sie sind
schnell aber nicht schnell genug adelie
bleibt auf Platz
das war geil
oder bin richtig bin halb gestorben aber
jetzt besser hätte die World Solar
Challenge nicht beginnen können Fahrer
jan ist eine Traumrunde gelungen g
angefühlt aber das ein steht nicht
gedacht die die vor stß unter Minuten
deronkurren kN abgenommen das Team aus
Aachen startet damit von der Pol
Position ins
Rennen ist auf eins also ziemlich gut
würde ich sagen wir sind super happy vor
allem dass das Auto Heide da steht das
war oberste Priorität und ja wir können
jetzt feiern heute Abend aber das Rennen
ist noch lang deswegen dürfen wir uns
nicht zu früh freuen und Fokus setzen
und weiter konstant gut
Durchfahren der nächste Morgen um 7 Uhr
kurz vor dem Start letzte Vorbereitungen
Startaufstellung für die World Solar
Challenge 2023 hier in Darwin die
Fahrzeuge der Challenger Klasse fahren
nur mit Solarstrom und haben nicht mal
eine Ladesteckdose das heißt nur der
Strom der über solche Solarzellen ins
Auto geht bringt das Auto auch nach
vorne rund Z Jahre haben die Teams an
ihren Boliden gebaut der Fokus maximale
Effizienz aber auch maximale
Zuverlässigkeit von Antrieb Batterie und
wechsel ter viele Teile werden allein
für diese Fahrzeuge und die Teilnahme an
diesem Rennen designed und
hergestellt es muss einfach jetzt alles
klappen und jetzt ist auch nichts mehr
was wir noch machen können ein bisschen
wie wenn man eine Klausur reinläuft man
weiß elich ja man hat gelernt aber jetzt
ist halt
Schicksal darf er auf die K lange
Strecke nach insgesamt 38 Teams sind
dabei und schnell wird klar wer den Sieg
unter sich ausmachen dürfte doch jedes
Team verfolgt seine eigene Strategie für
die nächsten 5
Tage hier überholt ein niederländisches
Team Adeline der Favorit aus Belgien hat
sich bereits an die Spitze gesetzt an
zwei kontrollstoppps pro Tag muss jedes
Team exakt 30 Minuten pausieren e es mit
einem neuen Fahrer am steuerit weiter
geht wir fahren gerade im Schnitt so
knapp 100 und das ist schon echt viel
wenn wir das Tempo halten können was
aber nicht der Fall sein wird
wahrscheinlich das hängt stark vom
Wetter ab dann kommen wir sehr gut voran
noch 15
Minuten trotz harter Bedingungen bei
Temperaturen um die 40° Celsius adeli
funktioniert
tadellos und auch das ist Alltag im
Outback Buschbrände immer wieder
entzündet sich trockenes Gras gerodete
Flächen neben der Straße verhindern dass
sich die Flammen weiter
ausbreiten alle Teams passieren die
Stelle
problemlos der Rauch verringert aber
auch die Sonneneinstrahlung auf die
Solarzellen und kostet die Teams
wertvolle
Energie am Nachmittag des ersten
Renntags zieht noch ein Favorit am Team
Sonnenwagen vorbei beim kontrollstoppp
fährt das Team Twente direkt vor den
aenern ein die Fahrer müssen die
Solarzellen aufstellen ihre
individuellen Zusatzgewichte und
Wasservorräte aus dem Wagen holen und
dann läuft die Uhr der Wagen darf für 25
Minuten nicht berührt werden solarrennen
folgen einer eigenen Logik nicht immer
wird so schnell gefahren wie es
theoretisch möglich wäre die Solarzellen
sind ständig an das heißt das Auto fährt
teilweise sogar fast AAG weil Strom
reingeladen wird und Strom wieder
verbraucht wird wir fahren im Schatten
lieber schneller damit wir tendenziell
in der Sonne langsamer fahren können und
dadurch dann mehr Ladezeit haben 3,5
quadr Solarzellen erlaubt das Reglement
auf den Fahrzeugen die Leisten dann rund
1000 Watt adeli ist mit Platz 4 in der
Spitzengruppe unterwegs als der erste
Renntag um 17 Uhr zu Ende geht wo auch
immer ein solarwagen dann ist hält das
Team an und richtet die Solarzellen zur
Sonne aus um so viel Strom wie möglich
in die Batterie zu laden geschlafen wird
in
Zelten wir haben auch den campaubau
immer wieder trainiert als wir vorher am
Outback waren das war mir super wichtig
dass die Leute einfach in diese Abläufe
reinkommen weil wenn ich die ganze Zeit
Entscheidung treffen müsste dann würde
es überhaupt nicht funktionieren jeder
muss mitdenken und das tun sie auch am
nächsten Morgen geht es wieder früh raus
Zelte abbauen den nächsten Renntag
vorbereiten Tag 2 der World Solar
Challenge
2023 es ist kurz nach 6 die Sonne geht
auf und das heißt Laden für adelie den
solarrennwagen aus Aachen das Dach ist
bereits aufgeklappt das heißt die
Solarzellen sind Richtung Sonne
ausgerichtet und auf diese Art und Weise
werden allein 15% des Strombedarfs
gedeckt in den nächsten 2 Stunden bis
das Rennen hier beginnt um die nächsten
gut 700 km zu schaffen weiter Richtung
Süden weiter nach
edyade meh Sonne morgens und abends in
die Solarzellen kommt umso schneller
kann gefahren werden Winkel ist bei uns
besonders wichtig weil wir hinten
besonders große Solarmodule haben so
dass wir am liebsten natürlich die zur
Sonne perfekt im 90° Winkel ausrichten
möchten deswegen verschieben wir das
Auto immer noch ein paar Zentimeter und
paar Zentimeter machen da tatsächlich
auch immer ein paar Watt aus deswegen
ist das mein Herzblut dass wir da
perfekt stehen so dass wir jeden Watt
reinkriegen können das ist heute nicht
so perfekt gelaufen weil wir ein paar
Wolken haben das heißt wir müssen das
Auto ein bisschen später machen solange
der Verbrauch natürlich höher ist als
das was wir gerade reinkriegen lohnt
sich das natürlich nicht das Auto
anzumachen weil wir dann mehr
verbrauchen würden als wir gerade
reinkriegen das wollen wir natürlich
nicht aber jetzt gerade ist der Moment
erreicht deswegen haben wir gerade das
Auto angemacht und deswegen laden wir ab
jetzt knapp zwei Stunden morgen Sonne um
8 Uhr dürfen die Teams wieder
weiterfahren die Landschaft Australiens
fasziniert immer wieder mit besonderen
Felsformationen und ihrer unendlich
wirkenden Weite der Stuart Highway
durchschneidet das Outback wie eine
Lebensader auf ihm fahren die solarteams
von Nord nach Süd durch den
australischen Kontinent wir fahren
unsere Strategie machen unser Ding und
dann schauen wir was die anderen Teams
machen ob sie das Tempo durchhalten
können oder ob wir vielleicht noch mal
die Chance haben aufzuholen wir hatten
heute einmal kurz die Situation dass wir
an einer Baustellenampel standen da
haben wir 2 Minuten glaube ich verloren
aber die Ampelphase wäre sonst 6 7
Minuten gewesen das heißt war okay es
hätte deutlich schlimmer sein können das
und da konnten wir dann auch den Deckel
kurz anstellen und noch ein bisschen
extra Energie mitnehmen das heißt soweit
wirklich super absolut zufrieden mit dem
ganzen Team super gut eingespielt läuft
alles top
adeli läuft im Schnitt mit rund 80
Stunden kilomet wie ein Uhrwerk ohne
technische Probleme die Spitzenteams
fahren jeden Tag allein mit der Kraft
der Sonne über 500 km inzwischen gibt es
jedoch große Abstände die die Teams auf
Platz 2 und 3 haben den Kontrollpunkt
bereits wieder verlassen als adeli dort
ankommt doch permanent am Limit zu
fahren kann bei einem Langstreckenrennen
auch für die Spitzenteams bedeuten die
Technik zu sehr zu strapazieren und
auszuschalen adelie hat am Ende des
zweiten Renntags
1346 km der Gesamtstrecke hinter sich
[Musik]
gebracht
unser Ziel ist natürlich schneller
fahren zu können und mit den anderen
Teams mitzuhalten aber vor allen Dingen
auch und das ist viel wichtiger in
diesem langzeitrennen dass wir am Ende
ankommen dass wir nicht am vierten Tag
da stehen und es nicht bis ins Ziel
schaffen weil wir eben keine
Batterieladung mehr haben deswegen ist
das super wichtig dass wir Energie
reinkriegen um abzuschätzen wie schnell
wir fahren können um trotzdem noch am
letzten Tag am besten mit 1% Akku ins
Ziel zu fahren das aer Team ahnt jedoch
dass es schwer wird die schnelleren
Teams einzu zu holen die haben
leistungsfähigere Akkus und verfügen so
schlicht über mehr
Energie es gibt eine Gruppe von vier
Teams die eine ganz neue
Batterietechnologie verwenden das sind
Silizium Batteriezellen und die haben
dadurch eine höhere Kapazität und sind
ein bisschen leichter dafür aber auch
eine deutlich höheres Risiko einfach
weil sie weniger stabil sind vor allem
wenn sie sich tief entladen können sie
sehr gefährlich werden sind Temperatur
inbeständiger wir haben dagegen auch
sicherere Variante gewählt
litiumeisenphosphat was auch in der
Industrie sehr üblich ist heutzutage und
die macht auch bis jetzt überhaupt gar
keine
Probleme das Team Sonnenwagen könnte
durch adelis Zuverlässigkeit doch noch
auf einen der vorderen Plätze kommen die
achner setzen auf zigtausende
Trainingskilometer die sie wochenlang im
Outback abgespult haben um mit den
Widrigkeiten der Strecke klarzukommen
1400 km von 3000 km quer durch
Australien sind geschafft das
Outback jetzt mit einer besonderen
Herausforderung denn auf den nächsten
mehreren hundert kilomet gibt es starke
Seitenwinde es könnte sein dass das
deutsche Team der RWTH Aachen da wieder
aufholen kann denn die Konkurrenz der
etwas professionelleren niederländischen
und belgischen
hat einigen Vorsprung Alice Springs
mitten in Australien der nächste
Zwischenstopp die solarwagen
funktionieren trotz starker
Beanspruchung die Studierenden haben
bewiesen dass sie Autos bauen können
sagt Markus makazzi vom TÜV Nord der als
Beobachter das Rennen begleitet in den
Solarautos hier sind viele Komponenten
verbaut die so keine Anwendung im
normalen Gebrauch finden liegt einfach
daran dass die Motoren hier viel
effizienter noch arbeiten müssen als im
normalen Auto schon und wir haben
überall das Reichweitenproblem die Jungs
versuchen das noch zu optimieren
probieren neue Sachen aus was sie sich
überlegt haben es gibt ein Team was
einen Segel noch zusätzlich einsetzt
wenn der Wind günstig steht solche
Sachen finden wir im Normalgebrauch
natürlich nicht und da können die sich
hier ausprobieren und können das hinter
vielleicht dann irgendwie umsetzen
vielleicht nicht unbedingt mit einem
Segel an ein normalen Auto aber ich
denke dass die Erfahrung die hier
gesammelt werden können durchaus
umgesetzt werden können in Zukunft für
neue Elektromotoren für neue Technik die
vielleicht sich etablieren wird dann in
den Markt ob Startup sind ob die
Studenten bei größeren Firmen anfangen
ist dann steht auch ein ganzen anderen
Blatt die solarrennwagen sind so
effizient dass sie mit der Leistung
eines Föns auskommen sie beschleunigen
dadurch zwar langsam schaffen in der
Spitze aber Geschwindigkeiten von über
100 stundenkilomet um bei der World
Solar Challenge dauerhaft vorne
mitzufahren muss alles perfekt ablaufen
das merken auch die Studierenden aus
achen inzwischen sitzt Ihnen das nächste
Team im Nacken und wenige Kilometer
später ist es soweit das Solarauto der
Universität Michigan setzt seine
riskante Aufholjagd fort und kassiert
auch den
Sonnenwagen beim nächsten kontrollstopp
kommt adelie auf Platz 5
[Musik]
an das dann auch noch Michigan überholt
ist natürlich das war eher so ein
bisschen das wo wir jetzt nicht gerade
besonders gut gelaunt sind danach das
das passieren wird war aber heute morgen
schon abzusehen jetzt ist es ganz
spannend weil alle vier Teams die gerade
vor uns sind haben eine besondere
batteriechemie die wir nicht haben
und da zeigt sich dann halt wieder dass
ja bessere
Technik bessere Autos baut aufgeben
kommt für das Team Sonnenwagen nicht in
Frage doch am Abend ist die Stimmung im
Camp ziemlich betrübt dabei hatte man
sich ganz bewusst gegen die neueste
Silizium Batterietechnik entschieden die
haben jedoch die vorne
ihren Autos
verut litiumbatterie mit stiumanode ist
gerade der das heiße Teil was
Energiedichte angeht aber muss halt noch
daran forschen wie man sie sicherer
macht
und gerade aktuell würde ich sagen ist
LFP eine bessere Chemie für Autos das
ist
litiumisenphosphat und die Haup der
haupg entschieden haben ist Sicherheit
die Zelle hat ist sehr unanfällig
gegenüber thermischen Änderungen oder
wenn sie quasi irgendwie nicht so
behandelt wird wie sie behandelt werden
soll weil 2019 im Rennen man viel
gesehen hat dass Autos und vor allem
Batterien an die Grenze getrieben wurden
und dann angefangen haben zu brennen es
gab halt mehrere Zwischenfälle deswegen
wollten wir auf jeden Fall die
Sicherheit des Fahrers an erster Stelle
haben die Sicherheit über die maximale
Effizienz zu stellen bestimmt eine
richtige Entscheidung
doch an diesem Abend der inoffiziellen
Weltmeisterschaft fällt es dem Team rund
um die Batterie nicht leicht einzusehen
dass ihr Antriebskonzept nicht gut genug
ist um Spitzenzeiten zu realisieren wie
jeden Abend wird die Batterie ausgebaut
und von der Rennleitung verplommt über
Nacht
eingelagert am nächsten Morgen ist der
Kampfgeist zurück wenn schon nicht mit
der Batterie kann adelie vielleicht mit
ihrer ausgefeilten Aerodynamik
Punkten 4 der World Solar Challenge 2023
und es ist kühl geworden 13° im
australischen Outback heute Morgen und
windig und der Wind könnte ein
entscheidender Faktor werden an diesem
vierten Tag denn Seitenwind ist etwas
was diese auf fahtwind optimierten
solarrennwagen überhaupt nicht gut
abkönnen der Sonnenwagen aus Aachen
heißt übrigens adelie weil seine Form
von den adelie Pinguinen abgeleitet
wurde auch auch am vorletzten Tag des
Rennens läuft alles glatt neben den
Winden strapazieren vor allem kuhgitter
die leichtbaurennwagen das japanische
Team bleibt nach so einem kuhgitter
plötzlich liegen fieberhaft wird nach
der Ursache des schleifenden Hinterrades
[Musik]
gesucht Wir haben die Kohlefaser
Karosserieteile überprüft und
festgestellt dass sie im Bereich der
radaaufhängung gebrochen sind aus meiner
Sicht ein erheblicher
Schaden oder kann man das überhaupt
reparieren frage ich wir versuchen es
aber es wird sehr schwierig erst zwei
Stunden später kann das Team aus Japan
weiterfahren das Team Sonnenwagen liegt
damit sicher auf Platz 5 als es durch
den trockensten Abschnitt der gesamten
Strecke geht ohne nennenswerte Flora
macht der Wind allerdings die
kontrollstops zu einer Herausforderung
mit zur Sonne ausgerichtetem solardeckel
würde eine Windböhe ausreichen um adelie
umzuwerfen das Auto darf aber während
des stops nicht nicht berührt werden
also bilden die Studierenden aus achen
selbst den
Windschutz vorbei geht es an Koper pedis
opalmien die weit verstreuten
Schutthalden bilden den letzten
markanten Wegpunkt eher auch dieser
Renntag zu Ende geht bei exakt 2500 km
das abendliche Laden danach kommt der
Sonnenwagen in ein extra aufgebautes
Zelt noch in der Nacht wird der letzte
Renntag
vorbereitet
wir hab jetzt
Flasche ein wir machen gerade die
Solarzellen sauber weil sich sehr sehr
viel Staub auf der Struktur sammelt
Solarzellen sind nicht glatt wir haben
eine extra Beschichtung darauf damit das
Licht möglichst viel absorbiert wird und
nicht reflektiert und leider wird die
halt auch sehr dreckig deswegen machen
wir die jetzt
[Musik]
sauber der letzte Renntag noch einmal
Sonne tanken vor dem
endsport wir haben sowohl gestern Abend
als auch heute morgen noch mal richtig
Energie getank können jetzt auf Angriff
gehen wir wollen auf jeden Fall
mchigigen noch mal ein bisschen Stress
machen das gehört natürlich dazu auf den
letzten Renntagen ansonsten heßt
natürlich sicher ins Ziel kommen gut für
die geplante Aufholjagd die Morgensonne
meint es gut mit adelie lädt so viel
Strom wie noch nie im Rennen in die
Akkus des solarwagens fahrerisch bleibt
es durch den Wind jedoch anspruchsvoll
Auto ist sehr sehr aerodynamisch gebaut
das heißt jede windb schiebt das Auto
links und rechts wie halt beim PKW aber
halt noch mal deutlich stärker aber ich
meine wir haben fast über 2000 km hier
getestet genau bei diesen
Windbedingungen und genau für diesen
Moment halt also ich glaube ich bin sehr
gut vorbereitet
adel ist mit 95 kmh
Durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit
unterwegs das Rennen ist fast geschafft
Felix erreicht den allerletzten Kontroll
vollstopp in Port augasta an der
australischen
Südküste nach dieser 30 minütigen Pause
geht es direkt Richtung Ziel in
edyate sollte eins der führenden Teams
technische Probleme bekommen wäre Platz
4 in Reichweite ja gerade eben kam die
schlechte Nachricht aufus Handy der
Sonnenwagen hat sich
überschlagen angeblich ist dem Fahrer
nichts passiert das ist die wichtigste
Nachricht aber damit ist das Team der
RWTH aen ausgeschrieden aus der World
sol Challenge wir werden jetzt gleich
umdrehen
und schauen wie es dem Team
geht die Unfallstelle ist abgesichert
als wir ankommen Fahrer simon ist zur
Kontrolle auf dem Weg ins
Krankenhaus genau geguckt re
wir hatten den fünften Platz eigentlich
sicher
und ja das ist das ist irgendwo ja auch
das das Ding von dem Rennen dass man
trotzdem versucht zu pushen auch auch
wenn man sich einfach mit dem Platz
zufrieden geben könnte ich glaube das
wollte bei uns im Team niemand und wir
hatten noch genug Leistung in der
Batterie und heute ist ein super
sonniger Tag da wollten wir einfach noch
mal zeigen zeigen was unser Auto kann es
lief gut es lief sogar sehr gut will ich
behaupten für uns und ja das ist jetzt
halt
vorbei kann man nicht ändern trotzdem
starkes Team wir haben viel erreicht
wichtig dass es allen gut geht unser
Auto hat gut
gehalten einige Kilometer weiter haben
die anderen Fahrer in ihrem
Transportfahrzeug vom Unfall erfahren ja
vor allem zwei Jahre jetzt drafin
gearbeitet ne also das war neben dem
Studium jetzt zwei Jahre lang was heißt
neben im Studium ich war Vollzeit
Sonnenwagen und ganz nebenbei wenn ich
Zeit hatte habe ich noch studiert
haben wir jetzt zwei Jahre alle drauf
hin
gearbeitet und da steckt echt viel
Schweiß und Blut drinne ist ist immer
diesessse Risiko was mitfährt
m das will man nicht wahrhen dass es
passiert ist
ist sehr schlimm gerade diese ganze
Arbeit ich
weiß wie viel gearbeitet wurde an dem
Auto und was auch für dieses ganze
Projekt getan wurde ja das ist Wahnsinn
dass das jetzt so endet an einem
Rastplatz sammelt sich das Team
begutachtet den
Schaden die Rennleitung ist angekommen
markus machazzi war als Beobachter dabei
als der Unfall passierte wir hatten
tatsächlich schrägen Gegenwind der mit
dazu beigetragen hat und zwei Roadtrains
oder ein Roadtrain und ein großes
Fahrzeug was uns entgegenk die natürlich
dadurch dass sie einen kurzen Abstand
zueinander hatten ersten Druck ausgeübt
haben auf Fahrzeug und dann eine so
und das hat das ganze noch mal verstärkt
weil der Fahrer versucht hat dagegen zu
lenken und dementsprechend ist er dann
einfach abgetrieben worden erst auf die
linke Seite und hat dann angefangen sich
in den in den rechten Verkehr
einzudrehen ist dann von der rechten
Straße runter und hat sich da dann
überschlagen leider die Batterie des
sonnenwagens hat den Unfall unbeschadet
überstanden alle Bauteile sind noch da
wo sie sein sollten und funktionieren
auch noch ich wür sagen das elektrische
Herzstück unseres Wagens wir überlegt
haben woed von Batteriezellen platziert
werden
kann überhaupt liegen das ist relativ
unüblich den sch noch mal weiter runter
zu drücken nicht so hoch sind
und gibt keine gerade
kanteesesogen von uns zellhalter gefräst
eingeklebt eine eine magesid Batterie
jeder
[Applaus]
hin Check zurück ihm ist nichts passiert
sie sind zusammen angetreten um das
schnellste Solarauto der Welt zu bauen
und sie halten auch zusammen nachdem der
Traum geplatzt
ist weil ihr Auto den Unfall technisch
fast unbeschadet überstanden hat gewährt
die Rennleitung den Studierenden aus
Aachen die Ziellinie auf eigener Achse
zu überqueren mit Simon am Steuer ich
habe großes Vertrauen nach dem Crash uns
in unser Auto gewonnen noch mehr als
davor habe ich das Gefühl deswegen damit
eigentlich ganz wohl aber ist natürlich
trotzdem irgendwie ein bisschen ja
komisches Gefühl ein letztes Mal wird
adelie fahrbereit gemacht alle freuen
sich trotz des Ausscheidens wenigstens
symbolisch die Ziellinie überfahren zu
dürfen auf den letzten Metern in
Adelaides Innenstadt wird vielen im Team
klar was Sie geleistet haben adelie ist
vielleicht nicht das schnellste
Solarauto im Feld aber erwiesenermaßen
eines der sichersten
das spüren die Studierenden in genau
diesem
Moment sie haben zwei Dinge bewiesen
einmal das Auto hat tadellos
funktioniert und zum anderen haben Sie
einen Test durchgeführt auf den Sie
sicherlich hätten verzichten können das
Solarauto hat sich überschlagen und ist
immer noch fahrbereit dem Fahrer ist
nichts passiert die monokockstruktur die
die Studierenden ja selbst entwickelt
haben haben ihn vor Verletzungen bewahrt
es gibt nur ein paar Kratzer hat er mir
gesagt v sicherheitskurt alles in allem
für diese Studenten leider nicht der
Erfolg den sie sich erwünscht hatten
aber auf jeden Fall eine gute Erfahrung
für ihren weiteren Lebensweg als die
kommenden Ingenieure sei es in der
Elektromobilität oder sonst irgendwo bei
der nächsten Ausgabe soll wieder ein
Team aus Aachen in Australien an den
Start gehen mit dem Ziel dann einen
Platz auf dem Podium zu
erreichen